conservatives fighting critical race
during woke education celebrating some
big victories in florida a vast majority
of local school board candidates back
back governor ron desantis won their
elections last night
the winds flipped the ideological makeup
from liberal to conservative and are
likely to have a huge impact on what
kids are taught in that state
several of the candidates were also very
vocal about pandemic restrictions
tyrus you think about what happened
younkin got elected down in virginia
this is a big part of it uh this seems
to not be as big an issue
there was is this going to come back you
think as an issue in the fall elections
i think
the american especially american parents
are focused now and they're invested
because of the way they were treated
during the pandemic and now i this is
where i don't always think it's
necessarily going to be a necessarily
republican conservative thing it's going
to be the adult in the room thing this
is where moderate democrats have a
chance to fix
that progressive thing the present way
the woke style is being rejected one of
the best things about the whole twitter
purchase with is that we realize that
it's a lot more bots than we did i was
on this show when i said it's not two
percent it's like 20 to the point where
everyone's seeing how much of the woke
agenda and that critical race theory
stuff was not backed by actual real
people and when parents doesn't matter
whether you're a democrat or republican
you don't want i don't want my children
growing up thinking just because the
color of someone skins next to him is
something wrong with them and that's
what that stuff was doing so and parents
were vilified for it and they're coming
out in force and i said it's going to be
the mom and dads in this country who are
making the decision and we're seeing it
firsthand where normally most probably
wouldn't even vote in this situation but
they're making that point yeah
i would just say i've um long thought
that this would be the year of the
parent in terms of the midterm election
but it's not just the congressional
elections that matter and what ron
desantis has done is say okay i'm going
to put some muscle behind it and push
and so he got his name id and all the
resources that were needed in order to
make this change this will have a big
difference on the local level and
perhaps even then have a spillover
effect going forward i also think that
the pandemic issue is one that
it's not fading in the minds of people
like you might have something that
happens like the student loan thing
maybe people sort of forget about that
by november i don't think so but maybe
they do but on the pandemic restrictions
and what happened to children because of
it parents are not going to forget you
hear the same thing
absolutely and you know what what's so
interesting about this is that uh school
board races at one time were so low
voter turnout so uncontested uh it's the
silver lining of the pandemic on so many
levels parents finding out what their
kids were being taught the ideology that
was being pushed on them
and the fact that uh you know the
teachers had had a sense that they
control the kids that they own the kids
and it got the parents in a position
where they said we're going to start
bringing back this country our values or
the values that we thought were always
being taught we're not going to tolerate
this nonsense anymore i mean this is a
huge win and it's going to be reflected
big time in the midterms
the girls jesse jr how do you think
about these issues and are parents
reacting the right way
well i would never
try to be on a school board i'm just not
that type of person but i like the fact
that conservatives need to start at the
grassroots level conservatives do well
when it's bottom up not top down so
whether it's a school board whether it's
a dog catcher whether it's agricultural
commissioner whatever if you have
conservative common sense parents and
people out in the local politics
community
taking ownership of their towns and
their cities and their counties that
start something and then you build up
from that and then maybe that person
goes on to be city council or
congressman or
governor something like that start it
here because a lot of times conservative
parents they check out they they're at
work they don't get involved and it's
these like little knitty control freak
democrat libs they get involved in all
these like local things and they're all
seeing the next thing you know like the
whole town's going to hell all right so
it's it's good people are waking up how
the democrats you know they get in there
they want to control everything like you
know we need a stop sign here you know
like wear a mask yeah wear a mask and
all of a sudden you're like what
happened to my city
you know how it is with that coming up
hillary clinton hillary clinton losing
another big contest we'll tell you about
it in the past
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now